[Musica]
costa di più la bottiglia di vino o il
mazzetto di asparagi
non è una domanda trucco più o meno
euro più euro meno allo stesso prezzo
potete facilmente verificarlo non hanno
mercato nano in un meno 3 le cose
cambiano però si richiedono vale di più
la bottiglia di vino o vale di più il
mazzetto di asparagi e qui tutti noi
abbiamo la stessa parola per rispondere
dipende dipende dal contesto dipende
dalla situazione in ultima analisi
diciamo che dipende dal vello dal
significato stesso che noi diamo la
parola valore
ora proviamo a spostare un attimo la
nostra attenzione da quella che gli
anglosassoni e gli analisti sistemi si
chiamano user side speck tve quella
dell'utente finale che ha a disposizione
un metodo di contabilizzazione relativa
del prezzo delle cose molto facile il
costo il costo la spostiamo l'attenzione
a quello che si chiama d'honneur site
spect il e ad esempio andiamo a vedere
qual è il costo a monte della bottiglia
di vino e del massetto di asparagi
questa bottiglia di vino è il risultato
di una produzione come si dice a km zero
no il vino siciliano questo mazzetto di
asparagi viene dal perù cosa vuol dire
che viene dal perù vuol dire che in perù
ci sono stati dei contadini che hanno
coltivato questi a spargi li hanno
raccolti li hanno puniti gli hanno
sagomati mazzetti li hanno portati sulla
costa gli hanno messo in un container
container stato messo in un cargo che è
risalito le coste del perù è passato
attraverso il canale di panama ha fatto
15.000 km arrivata sulle coste europee
sulle coste europee sono stati pagati i
dazi doganali necessari a questo punto
un altro viaggio in camion di qualche
migliaia di km l'ha portato qui in
italia è stato preso in mano dalle
grandi case distributrici è stato poi
passato ai venditori al dettaglio
finalmente arrivato al mercato di
catania dov'è stato comperato ed è qui
questa sera
questa mattina
in questo tavolino com'è possibile che
vi sia una così violenta separazione fra
il prezzo che poi alla fine noi paghiamo
per il vino e per gli asparagi e il
costo complessivo di tutto quello che è
stato fatto tutto quello che stato
investito per avere per dare a me oggi
la possibilità di avere questo mazzetto
di asparagi qui sul sul tavolo
evidentemente è necessario un cambio di
prospettiva
ora questa è un quartiere di san paolo
del brasile sembra un fotomontaggio no e
invece no c'è un muro che separa la
favela a sinistra dal quartiere dei
ricchi a destra dove vedete ciascuno
degli abitanti a una a una piscina
terrazza incredibilmente ora
incidentalmente mio nonno è nato qui e
credetemi io non ho mai saputo se è nato
nella parte sinistra della fotografia o
nella parte destra
quello però che so è che io non vorrei
vivere nella parte sinistra ma non
vorrei vivere neppure nella parte destra
ora questa immagine rappresentativa
delle disuguaglianze sociali che assieme
a guerre fame migrazione di massa
costituiscono quella tipologia di
problemi che sembrano essere refrattari
al tentativo di essere risolti
io mi sono chiesto e molti di voi
saranno chieste com'è possibile che
centinaia di persone molto migliori di
me è molto più in gamba di mac in gamba
di voi in possesso dei mezzi e della
volontà per farlo
nell'arco di decenni se non secoli non
siano riuscite a trovare la minima
soluzione a questi problemi
le guerre adesso fanno gli stessi morti
che facevano 50 anni fa anzi la
percentuale di morti tra i civili
rispetto ai morti militari è esplosa
esplosa com'è possibile
è evidente che c'è bisogno di un cambio
di prospettive di pensiero questa è una
citazione di albert einstein che diceva
che i problemi significativi di fronte
ai quali siamo oggi non possono essere
risolti dallo stesso tipo di pensiero
chi li ha creati
te li ha creati ora questa è una
citazione che viene che viene fatta
spesso in molti
testi trovate mi però qualcuno che in
qualche modo vi spieghi come fare ora
una possibile risposta viene quella da
quella che si chiama analisi sistemica
system thinking nella parola corretta
ora che si tratti di un mazzetto di
asparagi che si tratta di una bottiglia
di vino che si tratti di un quartiere di
san paolo ma anche che si tratti che ne
so della vostra bicicletta di una
fabbrica di un impianto nucleare di una
spiaggia di un ecosistema di un pesce o
della nazionale italiana di fioretto
maschile bene
lo schema è sempre questo qualcosa entra
da sinistra subisce una serie di
trasformazioni di processi e esce a
destra come risultato esce il mazzetto
di asparagi che io adesso ho sul tavolo
per ottenere questo risultato hanno
concorso tutta una serie di risorse che
di volta in volta assumono l'aspetto di
materie prime energia lavoro trasporti
informazione danaro ora vedete se voi
volete provare a dare un valore al
mazzetto di asparagi quantificandolo
avete la necessità di mettere insieme
tutti questi flussi di risorse quindi di
sommare le pere con le mele un tabù fin
da quando siamo piccoli alle elementari
ci dicono muay sommare le pere con le
mele
questa è la versione un pochino più
scientifica di un diagramma sistemico
per un processo produttivo qualsiasi
ripeto quando parlo di processo
produttivo
parlo di processo produttivo di un
oggetto ma anche di un servizio questo
qui può essere la sanità pubblica può
essere l'apparato che gestisce il
diritto internazionale piuttosto che il
diritto penale bene vedete vengono prese
delle risorse rinnovabili e no
queste risorse vengono processate grazie
all'intervento di beni danaro
quant'altro che viene dalla società e
soprattutto dall intervento di lavoro e
servizi
due cose sono interessanti da osservare
in questo in questo diagramma secondo me
innanzitutto vedete che tutti i flussi
che badate bene sono quantificabili
tutte le frecce hanno un inizio e una
fine
salvo a freccia tratteggiata che è
quella rappresentativa del danaro
il danaro fluisce circolarmente e paga
il lavoro i servizi in effetti ha un
ruolo particolare il flusso di danaro
perché perché il danaro in fondo non è
qualcosa che da lì arriva qui danaro è
un numero sul terminale di un computer
che permette incredibilmente il
passaggio di cose le risorse da qui la
seconda cosa interessante è che questo è
un invito a cominciare a cambiare
prospettiva di pensiero seconda cosa
interessante è che il danaro non paga le
cose paga gli uomini cercate di tenerlo
sempre a mente
noi non paghiamo la benzina non paghiamo
la casa non paghiamo noi paghiamo le
persone che ci consentono di entrare in
possesso della benzina o della casa
paghiamo il loro lavoro e paghiamo i
servizi quindi con gli asparagi noi
paghiamo una serie di persone che
neanche conosciamo di cui al limite
neanche sospettiamo l'esistenza problema
quindi è quello di sommare le pere con
le mele apparentemente un una difficoltà
insormontabile
l'analisi sistemica ci dà un
suggerimento su come è possibile farlo è
possibile farlo attraverso una quantità
che si chiama energia con la m che
rappresenta quantitativamente la memoria
virtuale di tutto quello che è stato
investito per ottenere il mazzetto
d'asparagi il quartiere di san paolo
l'energia quindi raccoglie materia
energia informazione danaro li converte
tutti nella stessa unità di misura che è
s j
ora io non sono qui per parlarvi di
energia o per dirvi che cosa sono gli
assi j
anzi vi lascio a bella posta con la
curiosità quello che posso dirvi però
che in questo modo io posso stabilire
quanti sj sono virtualmente contenuti
virtualmente associati a un chilo di
carbone piuttosto che un bit di
informazione piuttosto che un kraft
quanti esigeva le graffe quanti si j
vale o contiene meglio ancora la
bottiglia di
allo stesso modo posso quantificare gli
assi j per ora lavorativa a seconda del
tipo di lavoro ea si chiede il mio gatto
pensate quanta informazione è codificata
ed è servita per creare mio gatto
modificate adesso nel suo dna o gli assi
jay per proiettile questo risultato
nella ricerca che abbiamo fatto assieme
agli amici di emergency l'associazione
di gino strada abbiamo calcolato quale
l'investimento a monte che serve per
produrre il proiettile di fucile
d'assalto
ora questo proiettile che vedete è
rappresentato il dischetto che giace nel
che sta sul suo perdonata il sedere del
proiettile che si chiama innesco
contiene le sostanze chimiche che sono
destinate a fare da detonante ritardante
accelerante per la nitrocellulosa e
costituisce l'esplosivo al suo interno
bene questi dischetti per qualsiasi
proiettile che siri kalashnikov oppure
che sia dm 16 contengono sostanze
chimiche che vengono da brasile stati
uniti unione europea e cina
ciascun credibile questo vuol dire che
c'è stato un investimento che è
realmente globale per produrre questo
proiettile sapete quanto costa 20
centesimi lo potete comprare in internet
non qui in italia ma costa 20 centesimi
com'è possibile che costi così poco una
possibile risposta evidentemente viene
data dal fatto che di questi proiettili
ne vengono prodotti 500 al secondo
24 ore al giorno sette giorni alla
settimana 500 proiettili di fucile
d'assalto vengono introdotti nel mercato
e se tanto mi dà tanto vuol dire che 500
vengono usati tra parentesi ricordatevi
che il problema non è quello del
commercio delle armi ma dei proietti un
kalashnikov i due a 70 anni
dovete avere i proiettili quindi vedete
come sia possibile acquisire una
prospettiva nuova
su pezzi di realtà che stanno che stanno
intorno a noi
quindi questo invece è un diagramma
rappresentativo di un'università
pubblica
ora ovviamente non ho
nessuna intenzione di entrare nel
dettaglio di quello che voi vedete è
rappresentato alle mie spalle
semplicemente questo dovrebbe
trasmettervi il messaggio di quanto
complessa sia una struttura come
l'università e non soffre università
ovviamente vedete che ciascuna freccia e
rappresentativa di un flusso di risorse
e vedete che all'interno della struttura
universitaria
ci sono dei sottosistemi dei serbatoi
dei processi che sono legati tra loro
attraverso una rete di feedback interni
estremamente complessa qual è il
messaggio
il messaggio è che se voi pensate che
sia possibile risolvere uno dei problemi
specifici all'interno dell'università
isolandolo secondo una catena lineare di
causa effetto
beh avete sbagliato non c'è alcuna
possibilità di risolvere localmente
all'interno del sistema
secondo strutture causa effetto i
problemi dell'università
l'università ha un input che in questo
caso è rappresentato dai teenagers che
vengono in alto a sinistra tirati giù
dagli alberi inseriti all'università
processati ed escono in qualità di
prodotto in qualità di laureati di
fianco a quello che costituisce il
secondo output fondamentale
dell'università cioè di informazione
tutto questo viene fatto attraverso una
circolazione di denaro
vedete che entra da destra e va a
sinistra
ora il messaggio che mi piacerebbe darvi
è duplice da una parte la mia opinione è
che sia assolutamente vitale vitale in
questo momento introdurre l'analisi
sistemi car non necessariamente quella
energetica all'interno dei curricula
universitari che uno studia economia che
studi lingua che studi scienze che studi
giornalismo è necessario che vi sia una
capacità di inquadrare sistemicamente i
pezzi di realtà con cui la sua
disciplina lo mette al contratto quindi
che si tratti di qualcosa che produce
asparagi produce vino produce quartieri
cittadini o produce profughi
guerra l'idea è quella di chiedersi
innanzitutto ma il sistema che dà luogo
a questo pezzo di realtà che sta
osservando
a cosa è destinato qual è il suo vero
scopo si tratta dell'output desiderato
dell'output sistemico
oppure è un effetto collaterale è
qualcosa che compare come risultato ma
lo scopo è un altro chiedetevi e non vi
darò la risposta qual è la differenza
sistemica fra lo scopo di un'università
pubblica e di un'università privata
anche se apparentemente funzionano allo
stesso modo lo scopo sistemico e diverso
e questo vi apre una prospettiva di
abitua vi insegna ci insegna a pensarla
in modo diverso quindi chiedetevi ogni
volta che pensate un pezzo di realtà
attorno a voi il sistema che l'ha
prodotto che cosa è destinato a produrre
in realtà di quali risorse ha bisogno
per svolgere il suo compito
chi le fornisce queste risorse e perché
provate a farvi queste domande
io ho cominciato a farmele qualche anno
fa e entrando in questa in questa
prospettiva mentale diversa facendomi le
domande giuste
magari spero penso in tutta modestia di
aver cominciato a individuare anche
alcune delle risposte giuste facendovi
queste domande vi accorgerete che anche
se le pere e le mele sono due cose
diverse
è vero è un tabù non posso sommarle
assieme ma se io le sbuccio ritaglio a
dadini
in fondo in fondo non sono così vi
farete
[Applauso]